JAMES PATTERSON IS ONE OF
THE BEST-SELLING AUTHORS
IN HISTORY OVER
300 MILLION, COPIES OF HIS
BOOKS HAVE BEEN SOLD
WORLDWIDE. SO YEAH,
JAMES PATTERSON WITH HIS
EMPIRE OF BOOKS AND MOVIES AND
TV SHOWS
ABOUT A LOT,
BUT HE DOESN'T KNOW WHAT
IT'S LIKE TO SIT IN THE
SITUATION ROOM OR HAVE ACCESS
TO NUCLEAR CODES
AND LUCKY FOR HIM,
HE KNOWS A GUY WHO DOES SO IN
2018 PATTERSON TEAMED UP WITH
FORMER PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON
FOR THEIR FIRST POLITICAL
THRILLER. THE PRESIDENT IS
MISSING IT IMMEDIATELY SHOT
TO NUMBER
ONE ON THE NEW YORK TIMES,
BESTSELLER LIST NOW.
PATTERSON, AND CLINTON ARE OUT
WITH THEIR SECOND BOOK, THE
PRESIDENT'S DAUGHTER, WHICH
TELLS THE STORY
OF A FORMER PRESIDENT,
WHOSE DAUGHTER IS
IS KIDNAPPED BY TERRORISTS AND
JOINING ME NOW IS JAMES
PATTERSON. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
SO
IT'S NICE TO TALK TO YOU.
SO HOW AND WHY DID
YOU DECIDE TO PARTNER
WITH PRESIDENT CLINTON ON
THESE BOOKS? IT'S SUCH A COOL
PARTNERSHIP. YOU HAVE
I NEEDED MORE TORTURE,
YOU KNOW,
WE BECOME NICE FRIENDS.
AND I MISS WORKING WITH THEM.
WE HAVE A GOOD PARTNERSHIP AND
I THINK THE PARTNERSHIP
IS BASED ON TWO THINGS. ONE
WE HAD WE RESPECT ONE
ANOTHER AND SECONDLY WE
LISTEN TO ONE ANOTHER
AND
YOU KNOW I MEAN IT HAS BECOME
A FRIENDSHIP. HE WHAT DID HE
GIVE ME?
I
BELIEVE FOR SOCIALIST FOR
CHRISTMAS AS A CHRISTMAS
PRESENT
AND YEAH. AND WE THOUGHT
WE HAD ANOTHER DIFFERENT KIND
OF A BOOK. THE FIRST BOOK,
THE PRESIDENT IS MISSING
IS ABOUT A PRESIDENT WHO'S IN
OFFICE
AND
HE
DEALS WITH
CYBER SECURITY PROBLEMS, WHICH
OBVIOUSLY,
IT'S REALLY IN THE NEWS RIGHT
NOW,
BUT WE DEALT WITH IT IN A
BIG WAY IN THE BOOK IN
2018.
THE SECOND BOOK IS
A PRESIDENT WHO'S OUT OF
OFFICE.
AND
HE DEALS
AND IT'S A MUCH MORE.
IT JUST DEALS WITH THE
HUMANITY OF A PRESIDENT,
MAKING A PRESIDENT HUMAN.
I MEAN, IT'S SUCH A COOL THING
TO THINK ABOUT DOING.
A BOOK LIKE THIS WITH A FORMER
PRESIDENT. WHAT EXACTLY IS THE
PROCESS THAT YOU GO THROUGH
WHEN YOU'RE COAT WRITING A
BOOK WITH A FORMER PRESIDENT,
DO YOU HAVE MEETINGS, YOU
HAVE ZOOMS. IT WAS THE
PANDEMIC,
I'M ASSUMING A PART OF THE
PROCESS AT LEAST.
YEAH.
NOW WE
WITH THE OUTLINE. WE GO BACK,
FIVE SIX, SEVEN TIMES JUST
YOU KNOW
STREAMLINING AND MAKING IT
TIGHTER
HEARING THE CHARACTER SO THAT
THEY'RE MORE INTERESTING.
AND THEN
WE'LL JUST GO BACK AND FORTH
EVERY WEEK WITH PAGES.
HE'LL WRITE SOME OUR RIGHTS
WHAT SEPARATES THE
PRESIDENT'S DAUGHTER? I THINK,
FROM FROM MOST THRILLERS,
IT'S JUST THE AUTHENTICITY
THAT HE BRINGS TO IT.
I MEAN,
A LOT OF WRITERS AND WE'VE HAD
A LOT OF BLURBS AND THINGS AND
PEOPLE JUST SAY IT'S A FREIGHT
TRAIN THAT THE ACTION NEVER
STOPS,
BUT I THINK THE OTHER PIECE OF
IT IS
IS IS THAT THE
IT JUST SO AUTHENTIC.
I MEAN SOME OF THE THINGS
ALTHOUGH IT'S HARD TO SAY
ANYTHING COULDN'T HAPPEN IN
THIS DAY AND AGE BECAUSE
EVERYTHING SEEMS TO BE ABLE TO
HAPPEN.
BUT
IF SUCH AND SUCH HAPPENED,
THE PRESIDENT CAN TAKE A,
HERE'S HOW IT WOULD HAPPEN,
HERE'S WHAT THE SECRET SERVICE
WOULD DO.
HERE'S WHAT, WHAT, WHAT I
WOULD BE CAPABLE
DOING. HERE'S WHAT I COULDN'T
DO, HERE'S WHO I MIGHT REACH
OUT TO FOR HELP.
HERE'S WHAT IT'S LIKE
TO GROW UP.
SORRY,
RIGHT,
EXACTLY.
BUT IT MAKES ME THINK ABOUT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
IMAGINE IS DIFFICULT.
EVEN THOUGH YOU HAVE A FORMER
PRESIDENT POLITICS IN REAL
LIFE, RIGHT NOW,
IT'S A LITTLE BIT
NUTS, RIGHT? SO HOW DO YOU
MAKE SURE TO MAKE
A POLITICAL
THRILLER COMPELLING? BUT ALSO
TRY TO KEEP IT GROUNDED
IN WHAT COULD POTENTIALLY BE
REALITY.
WELL, I THINK IT IS VERY
GRATITUDE HAS TO BE WITH
WITH CLINTON INVOLVED.
BUT I, YOU KNOW,
ONE OF THE THINGS IN BOTH OF
THESE BOOKS, IS
WE MAKE SURE THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS A GOOD HUMAN
BEING.
AND I THINK THAT'S USEFUL FOR
PEOPLE. I THINK PEOPLE WANT
IT, I THINK NO MATTER WHAT
PEOPLE'S POLITICS ARE LEFT
OR RIGHT. I THINK
MOST PEOPLE AGREE THAT BIDEN
IS A GOOD PERSON. YOU
MAY DISAGREE
WITH HIS POLICIES. YOU MAY
THINK HIS POLICIES ARE GREAT,
BUT WE BOTH FELT IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO HAVE A PRESIDENT.
AND IN THE PRESIDENT'S
DAUGHTER WHERE PEOPLE GO, HE'S
A GOOD HUMAN BEING
AND THEN TO HUMANIZE THEM.
AND WHAT COULD BE MORE
SUCH A HUMAN THINGHAT WE
CAN ALL IDENTIFY
BY WITH, WHICH IS, WHICH IS
ONE OF YOUR LOVED ONES. IN
THIS CASE, A DAUGHTER
BEING IN JEOPARDY, AND SHE IS
KIDNAPPED
AND HE'S IN A POSITION WHERE
HE CAN HELP TO FIND
HER
AND WE WOULD ALL IF WE IF THAT
WAS IN OUR POWER, WE WOULD DO
THAT. WE CAN ALL IDENTIFY
WHO ARE FIREMEN SURE YOUR
PARENTS WOULD BE A, OH MY GOD,
GOD. MY LITTLE GIRL IS
MISSING,
YOU KNOW, IT'S TERRIBLE.
AND SO WE ALL CAN WE ALL CAN
FIELD.
SO YEAH, THE PRESIDENT'S
DAUGHTER IN THIS BOOK MEL IS
KIDNAPPED BUT SHE'S ALSO THE
HERO, RIGHT
OF THE STORY. WHAT WAS THE
IDEA BEHIND THAT
CHARACTER?
YEAH, SHE IS THE HERO.
I MEAN,
ONE OF THE THINGS HE DOES
WHICH IS GREAT FOR ME
AND IT I THINK IT MAKES THE
BOOKS WITH HIM BETTER
THAN
SOMETIMES. WHAT I DO ON MY OWN
IS HE KEEPS PUSHING AND
PUSHING AND PUSHING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE CHARACTERS ARE
ROUNDED THAT THEY'RE
COMPLICATED,
THAT THERE'S GOOD THINGS AND
BAD THINGS.
AT THEM AND MAL,
I THINK THE PRESIDENT AND I
BOTH AGREE THAT HE'S OUR,
SHE'S OUR FAVORITE CHARACTER
IN THE BOOK, JUST BECAUSE OF
HOW SHE HANDLES
ADVERSITY.
SHE'S COURAGEOUS, BUT NOT IN
A RIDICULOUS WAY
SHE WANTS TO SURVIVE.
AND SHE DOES SORT OF
CREDIBLY
HEROIC THINGS ALONG THE WAY.
HOPEFULLY,
SHE'LL SURVIVE. I'M NOT GOING
TO RUIN THE ENDING HERE
BUT
BUT I GUARANTEE YOU THERE WILL
BE SOME SURPRISES.
I'M SOME TWISTS AND TURNS THAT
YOU WON'T EXPECT.
SPECT IN THE
PRESIDENT'S DAUGHTER.
DO YOU GET THE IDEA THAT
A FORMER PRESIDENT WHO HAS
LIVED SORT OF THE REAL
AND
UNPREDICTABLE LIFE OF A
PRESIDENT WHERE YOU WAKE UP IN
THE MORNING AND YOU KNOW,
YOU THINK YOUR SCHEDULE IS ONE
THING BUT THEN YOU HAVE TO GO
TO THE
SITUATION ROOM. DOES THAT HELP
IN THE PROCESS OF CREATING A
POLITICAL THRILLER
BECAUSE HE CAN PULL ON THOSE
MOMENTS WHERE IT WAS
A CRISIS MODE.
IMMEDIATELY AT THE DROP OF A
DIME.
YES.
NO, ABSOLUTELY. I MEAN HE'S
BEEN THROUGH IT. IT'S THERE'S
NOTHING LIKE IT. HE'S BEEN
THROUGH IT AS A PRESIDENT.
HE'S BEEN THROUGH IT AS A
PARENT
AND HILLARY THE SAME WAY
AND HILLARY YOU KNOW, HILLARY
AND I THAT WE BECOME FRIENDLY
TO. AND AND SHE READ THE
BOOK AND
AN APPROVED WHICH IS WHICH IS
THERE SHE IS. CLICK YEAH,
HILLARY CLINTON.
YEAH, YEAH.
HILLARY COULD, I WORKED FOR
HILLARY CLINTON. SO I
HAVE A LITTLE BIT
BIASED WHEN IT COMES TO
TO HILLARY CLINTON, SHE IS
SHE IS A VERY WARM AND,
AND COMPELLING HUMAN.
I AGREE. YOU KNOW, JUST A
QUICK STORY, YOU KNOW, BECAUSE
WE KNOW THEM PRETTY WELL
KNOWN. THE FIRST TIME WE WENT
OUT TO DINNER
BY WIFE AND I WITH, WITH
HILLARY AND THE PRESIDENT BILL
AND HILLARY,
I WAS LOGGED IN, ER,
AND THREE OR FOUR TIMES DURING
THE MEAL, WE SAW THAT THEY
WERE HOLDING HANDS UNDER THE
TABLE
AND THAT'S NOT THE WAY PEOPLE
PERCEIVE THEM, BUT
THEY'RE WRONG.
AND, AND ONE OF THE GREAT
THINGS ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S
DAUGHTER IS
YOU REALLY FEEL THE HUMANITY
OF THIS PRESIDENT, AND
YOU FEEL THE HUMANITY OF THE
FORMER FIRST LADY. AND
AND THE DAUGHTER AS WELL.
IS WELL YOU FEEL THEM, YOU
BELIEVE IN THEM YOU YOU WANT
THE WHAT THIS TO HAVE A GOOD
ENDING
THE STORY?
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE. THE BOOK IS
PRESIDENT'S DAUGHTER,
JAMES, PATTERSON, IT WAS A
PLEASURE. PLEASE STAY SAFE.
I
PROMISED YOUR WATCHES THAT
THEY WILL NOT PUT THIS ONE
DOWN. IT DOES MOVE.
IT IS A FREIGHT TRAIN SO
THANK YOU. NICE TO NICE TO
TALK.
I LOVE BOOKS LIKE THAT.
THANK YO